we knew it off the top of our head that
patrick mahomes is going to play on
sunday it's just a matter of time folks
let's hear from andy reid speaking to
the media yesterday choosing his words
carefully because it is a little bit of
a minefield for a coach to say whether
or not a player with a concussion is
going to be cleared to play but you can
read between the lines or the tea leaves
as the case may be here's andy reid
talking about mahomes
yeah i'm sure he looked good he's just
uh he's in the protocol so there's only
certain things he can do and
a limited basis but
today is a little bit limited practice
so he this fit right into what he could
do and
and um but he took all the snaps and
you know he feels
he feels good so i mean we just we're
just going to follow this protocol
as close as we possibly can
of course that's all they can do but he
was able to practice it wasn't full
contact i think as it relates to the
five-step process under the protocol
he's in step three okay and and
obviously look he's not cleared until
he's cleared but all signs are pointing
to patrick holmes being cleared
officially yesterday he was a limited
participant in practice concussion
and toe we expected that we'll see what
happens today tomorrow my guess is he'll
be labeled as questionable just in case
and then we wait and see for him to show
up and play on sunday and i think that
he will i i'm always uncomfortable when
the team reportedly is optimistic i
don't think as i said yesterday they
should be anyistic when it comes to this
right but i i i think it's naive
to assume he won't play i think he's
going to be good to go and
and the chiefs are going to be the
chiefs when they play the bills on
sunday and it should be a great game it
should be a great game i'm with you i
mean you know it's it's one i would be
just shocked if he doesn't play i really
would be i mean like i said on monday
i'd cry i might cry sunday morning if i
find out patrick mahomes is going to
play i will that will just be a dagger
to the heart and you know i'll bring up
one thing too to like you know i was
talking about this with my dad last
night and you said it earlier this week
i mean
really whoever that
that you know what the impartial guy
that's gonna you know
check him out for the concussion i'm
messing up with the word independent
the official name is even more fancy
than that but it's the independent
narrative right like he's gonna have to
be living under a rock to not know the
magnitude of the guy he's checking out
in this game and what's going on in this
country and this weekend with afc nfc
championship game so that's going to
play into this and i i would
i would say mike yesterday they probably
had
that limited practice deliberately so
patrick mahomes could
be a part of the whole practice instead
of him oh wait you're not allowed to run
and do physical exertion so now you have
to sit and watch this part of practice
andy just said nope we're going to have
a walk through the whole practice is
going to be a two hour walk through and
then patrick mahomes can do it and go
through all the mechanics and all that
and they still void the concussion
protocol issues there so smart play by
them and i wouldn't be shocked if we
heard that again today really
you know that thought crossed my mind
and i hadn't articulated it the idea
that wednesday is usually the big work
day in advance of a sunday game they
played on sunday like they normally do
during a football season except when
you're a marquee team and you have games
on other days but usually the sunday to
sunday schedule is wednesday is your big
practice day and maybe this week is
going to be thursday or maybe it won't
be i don't know but i think you're right
i think they curtailed the intensity of
the practice to allow patrick mahomes to
fully participate in it and uh and we'll
see how he progresses
on that path toward being cleared to
play
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports